how to prepare for a future business so
I got a great question from Matthew
who's on my newsletter list love you
guys and I've been going back and
forward with Matthew a little bit on
email and here's what Matthew wants to
do okay he wants to launch a business
but not yet he's about to join the the
Marines I think it's a four-year program
and after that he's thinking about
launching his own business something to
do with a gym or personal fitness he
wants to figure that out but he wants to
help inspire people to be active and do
things with their lives and not just sit
on the couch and be lazy
this is his goal and so he's saying okay
I know I want to launch his business and
you know four years what do I do now to
start getting ready for so Matthew
congratulations being so proactive it's
great to have this thing you know this
goal mapped out for you what I would do
now so join in the Marines I would try
to see every experience with them
through the eyes of launching your own
business so you're interested in
entrepreneurship you're interested
interested in personal fitness and
you're interested in people taking
action everything that you experience
with the Marines should be seen through
this lens so you want to learn as much
about personal fitness as you can when
you're in the Marines right now no
you're gonna you're gonna be put through
you're gonna be put through the ropes in
the Marines but as much as you can about
their workout routine and maybe you can
look at the history of it and learn from
the sergeant's there and learn from the
people who are more experienced there
the Marines also have a business and
they have stuff that they sell and
license maybe you can get involved on
that side and learn about how they brand
themselves and how they create new
products that they sell you know if you
look at motivation right that's part of
what you want to do you can look at how
do the Marines motivate people how can
you learn so with your whole time there
you're not just gonna be a Marine you're
gonna be a sponge you're gonna be an
entrepreneur sponge learning these
things and trying to proactively seek
out projects that you can get involved
in that you can leverage what you've
learned when you eventually are done
with
and you're ready to launch your own
business the other thing that always
encouraged you to do is start now you
know too many entrepreneurs who have
this dream for what they want to do in
the future they said okay well when I
get there I'll start my business you can
start now building an audience and and
building up your expertise and skill set
so what do I mean by that is you could
start now by telling your story okay and
what I don't want to have happen is
you're in Orissa for years and then boom
you got a start and you're starting from
square one if you start now and even
YouTube is a great place to start if
you're doing a YouTube or a blog you
basically start by telling your story
you talk about why you're starting this
thing up here's your here's my vision
here's what I want to create and then
you document over the next four years I
really think that you're doing the
things that you're scared about the
things that are working for you the
things that you're learning and how you
think this could be a business idea
share all that because you're going to
start building up a community and an
audience of people who will want to hear
from you and then in four years when
you're ready to launch your company you
have this following already that you can
bring along with you and it may not be
crit in the gym it may be something
totally different who knows what the
idea would be after you go through the
Marines and after you get all this
support from your audience examples a
friend of mine named Bailey who recently
launched a new YouTube channel and she's
going on this journey of self-discovery
and she was basically unhappy with what
she was doing you know in her business
she liked her company but she needed a
bigger challenge he was something new
she does know what it looks like and so
she's going on this journey and she's
documenting the whole process and what
it does is it brings people along with
her you want to be able to post the
things that also make you scared and
things you're not sure about because
that's part of the journey right people
want to look back and see how you got to
where you are now and not just you
summarizing and telling it but
witnessing you along the way and the
things that you're scared about and the
things that you're not sure about and
how you got to where you are that builds
that builds
chin and so these four years math you
can be building this thing up and have
this huge community of of YouTube
viewers or blog readers or newsletter
subscribers whatever it is that that not
only are ready to buy whatever he has
when is really the sell it but also give
him constant motivation you know the
best part of my day is seen the comments
that come in on the YouTube videos you
guys keep me excited and motivated every
day when you're leaving the comments and
you say how much I've helped you with
your business and your motivation I love
that stuff and so you guys should all be
doing this in your companies as well
and if you're thinking about launching
business like Matthew is start
documenting the process now and getting
feedback now and at the start you're
gonna feel like you're talking to
yourself that's okay
put it up on your Facebook some of your
friends will join in the conversation
you're doing this to do it I know that
other people be inspired by your journey
and eventually this will be something
that will help millions of people
believe for those you watching like the
video thumbs up below leave a comment
you know how important it is to me leave
a comment if you have a question leave
it below in the comments and make a
video reply and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon